as you can see Lucy Bell the shadow
culture secretary joins us in the studio
lovely to see you this morning um but
should we should we start with manston
and that pretty damning inspector report
I mean at least when speaking to Robert
generic this morning there did appear to
be an acceptance that the conditions
there are are unacceptable his argument
however is this is not a situation of
the government's creation it is a
situation being created by those people
Smugglers who are getting people hidden
record numbers what's your view well
it's both is true isn't it because this
is about record numbers coming over here
uh nearly I think we're going to head
upwards of 40 000 coming across in small
boats this year alone that figure is up
from a few dozen a few years ago it's a
massive increase that's happened uh over
time people have been aware of it for a
long time and what I find sort of
startling is is the government's
position that somehow this is new news
to them that this is something they
hadn't foreseen this is something they
didn't know was coming they have been in
charge of our immigration system for 12
years now both Zoella bravaman Robert
generic and the rest of the of the
cabinet they have been in charge of this
immigration system for 12 years it is
broken but it's broken under their watch
so so what then would labor do
differently I mean as you said the
conservatives have obviously been
powerful for you know for for longer
than a decade and successive ministers
have tried to deal with this but it
doesn't seem that within the legal
framework that there currently is there
is any way that we can stop people
coming across the channel in small boats
well there are ways and that the things
that the government should have been
doing that a vet Cooper and the labor
party and others have been calling on
them to do for years to deal with some
of these uh issues and what we see time
and again from this government is high
rhetoric and then no action okay
so we should have had a much stronger
arrangement with the French instead we
have played fast and loose with our
relationship with the French when we've
needed them to to deal with some of
these issues further Upstream we
absolutely have to there are a lot more
we could do to to make some of the the
activities of the criminal gangs illegal
um the way they advertise on social
media for example and lots of other ways
of that their business model flourishes
which we should be cutting off at root
which we haven't been doing and we
critically at the moment we should be
processing much much faster the decision
making on some of these applications
because people can come over here and it
might take up for two years for their
process to be uh dealt with and all that
two years it's costing the taxpayer
expensive hotel costs and so on while
their Pro their applications are being
processed so they're just some of the
things they're doing but we're not going
to be held to account for this
government's failings on immigration
it's not the labor party's fault it's
not the labor party's problem it's this
government but we have been calling on
them for years to do action to deal with
it do you accept that for for many
people in this country this is a real
live issue not just those people who are
directly affected living on the south
coast Mr Janet was providing the example
of one Albanian who made his way into
someone's property and clearly that that
is unacceptable but but also in places
like the red wall that there is a real
desire to see some government of
whatever political Hue to actually get
to grips with this to stop people
risking their lives coming across the
channel and indeed for people who do
make it to this side of the English
Channel that they don't seem to be
receiving preferential treatment to just
as a random example people who are
staying living rough on the streets of
the UK well absolutely these are real
problems that people raise with me uh
all the time and and because they're not
being dealt with because we're seeing
such in
increases in numbers and then the
government not dealing with the
situation afterwards what we're seeing
this this dispersal policy that that
they have had over the last few years
just isn't working because it doesn't
come with the requisite funding that
local authorities need these hotels that
are being bought up for for processing
Asylum applications is causing problems
in local communities as well and it's
putting a lot of pressure under local
Services I can do that for myself it is
it is not racist it would not be racist
in your review Force someone to raise
significant concerns about the way in
which immigration policy has been has
been uh well has has not been pushed by
this government no it wouldn't be racist
because I think it is being very very
badly managed you know zuela Bravo and
Hazel said it is broken and it is broken
because we're seeing very very slow
processing times we're not seeing the
action on the criminal gangs we're
seeing huge numbers uh taking that that
decision to come across in in small
boats and the dispersal uh policies of
this government are are there not
working because you're seeing large
numbers uh being housed in in unsuitable
accommodation not able to work not able
to contribute putting uh pressure on
local services and local councils are
not being supported with those decisions
in fact local councils don't have any
say at all over whether
um these hotels or migrant centers can
be housed in their in their area yet
they are expected to deal with the
consequences of it so those failings are
on the government that's who they're on
well let's let's just just do very
specifically with them you know the
performance by swella bravaman at the
dispatch box in the House of Commons
yesterday a couple of things that she
said that would be good to get your view
on first that we are currently
experiencing an invasion on the south
coast second that she is the victim of a
political Witch Hunt well I'm sorry I
haven't I have little sympathy for for
swella Bravo somebody who's been found
to breach the ministerial code and
broken all protocols by emailing uh
private and secure government
information to her own Gmail account
which is then distributed uh to others
so she shouldn't still be in her post
for that alone I think her the language
that she used yesterday in the House of
Commons was deeply irresponsible uh
coming just 24 hours after we saw a fire
bomb attack on a Migrant Center in Kent
this will put our security services our
police local communities at higher risk
and it will put them on high alerts and
for the Home Secretary to put our
security services at greater strain
through incendiary language I think he's
deeply irresponsible I think there's an
incredibly emotivision no matter which
side of the political divide you've
Fallen it would certainly be hope us all
to just reduce the temperature
absolutely absolutely Lucy pal thanks
very much for joining us really
appreciate it